solidarité et entraide deux des valeurs
du rugby mise en lumière chaque année
par cette de coeur au programme de
nombreuses animations dont un tournoi
relevé qui se joue à sept contre sept
mais l'événement se distingue avec son
angle caritatif depuis son lancement le
tournoi à 7 de coeur a permis de
récolter trois cent vingt mille euros
pour des associations on le fait par le
biais de levée de fonds mais également
par des opérations de communication en
essayant d'avoir le plus beau résultat
pour pouvoir parler le mieux possible
des associations qui sont bénéficiaires
du tournoi
pour sa huitième édition cette de coeur
a soutenu cinq associations caritatives
dont celle de l'ancien international
français et entraîneur de biarritz
patrice lagisquet chrysalide accompagne
les parents d'enfants déficients mentaux
et laval tâche colin avec des des
tournois comme celui ci qui nous
permettent de
recueillir des fonds c'est que ça vous
donne une autonomie pour lancer des
projets on a été pionnier sur la
création d'une auxiliaire de vie
scolaire sur les premières classes
d'intégration dans les années au tout
début des années 90
et chaque fois c'est grâce à des
soutiens comme celui d'aujourd'hui que
qu'on a pu lancer ses projets sur le
terrain des joueurs venus de toute la
france mais aussi d'angleterre et de
chine
et parmi la trentaine d' équipes
représentées quelques habitués nous ça
fait ça fait pas mal d'années qu'on on
est là on est à versailles et et à
chaque fois c'est toujours un plaisir de
jouer ici de voir le niveau un peu et
surtout de participer à une asso
caritatives pour ces gens là et pour le
rugby en plus c'est un tournoi très
relevé sportivement et en même temps le
caritatif c'est la cerise sur le gâteau
c'est le fait de pouvoir jouer au rugby
et faire même temps une bonne action
bonne action transformer l'objectif de
90000 euros affiché cette année sera
probablement atteint